[Music]  are you hello  visitors from another planet there's no  need to fight anymore see friends they  took Lucy and the others hang on you  Franz plan  you mind if I save your life not at all  names Rex danger vest this is my [ __ ]  dinosaurs doing space aliens kidnapped  my friends I'm going to get them back by  an alien queen I'm a queen whatever  would not be the talking horse I could  change my fool if this makes you  uncomfortable  hey guys they'll go back the horse was  much more palatable come with me on this  adventure to save my friends teach me to  be tough let's go find your friends  [Music]  different did you dress double dots on  your face on the way out you gone  bruised up  you almost forgot me guys oh did we I'm  literally a lantern how did you miss me  [Music]